in what you had there was the economy is
recovering faster than expected the
long-term economic scarring from the
covered pandemic is
less severe than the office of budget
responsibility thought just a few months
ago so the economy will be two percent
smaller by the middle of the decade not
three percent smaller that does give the
chancellor you know 20 to 30 billion
more in money to
pay for that all now when you get to the
policy of this all
there has been talked about this tension
between rishi sunaka's wanted to be
fiscally conservative low tax
careful on spending and then the big
spender boris johnson i think that
budget showed who'd won out and it was
certainly i think framed as a boris
johnson budget or that's how i saw it i
think that's how economists and
observers will see it but yeah if you go
back to what you just said about labour
governments this is what paul johnson
from the institute of fiscal studies
said he said the 150 billion increase in
departmental spending over the
parliament that's a 3.8
real increase he said these are big
spending is much more
in common with brown and blair than
osborne and cameron so if you wanted
confirmation
that boris johnson is taking blair's
clothes and look no further than this
budget he signaled his intent to
remember when he announced uh the big
the big tax uh increase on national
insurance he said we are the party of
the nhs when he did that now
so there's big spending bigger spending
than we expected we'd expected that the
chancellor would put more away perhaps
for a rainy day because he himself said
that inflation is a concern it could run
up to four percent what if there's
another spike in covered cases um but is
it too good to be true almost and i
think that's where
rachel reeves came in there because from
a labour's perspective what they're
arguing is is when you look into the
figures and we're just looking through
them now
there's lots of tax increases here for
people
vat is going to go up 4 billion and then
9.3 billion
in per year for the next two years
council tax if you look at the office
for budget responsibility it's going to
go up to 12.1 billion up 33 from now uh
by 2026 seven so i think when we drill
into the numbers rishi sonnet talks a
lot about the big giveaways and a lot
about the spending and a lot about cuts
around alcohol gt fuel duty
but in it are there more tax rises for
people because i think the acid test of
this budget isn't the optics in the
chamber but in five six months time are
people struggling with inflation really
feeling the squeeze of the cost of
living or are their lives improving
under this and have we managed to work
out that key figure whether more is
being taken than is being spent or the
other way around
in terms of the tax take yeah well it
looks like that there's a there's a i
don't know yet actually i haven't worked
that out yet i haven't looked through
the red book but when you look into the
figures this is what i was making the
point on in terms of uh council tax on
vat there will be
much more hidden tax take than perhaps
was presented by the chancellor there
and politically boris johnson there
wearing his cop 26 blue planet badge
but labor
making a great deal both the prime
minister's questions and in their
applied to the budget over uh what's
been done on climate change issues well
exactly in that budget i mean
the prime minister announced a cut in
fuel duty and he announced uh a freezing
of uh fuel so airport
air passage and a freezing of fuel
jewels it hardly speaks to a a greener
agenda so there's a lot of talk about
being greener but then in some of the
policy decisions being taken it's not
reflected in actually
the black and white ink of the treasury